[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
well welcome everybody here to the um
utilities and
roading meeting um first up we've got
any apologies
on
right so
so we've got a mover for those then
and robbie in a second all in favor all
right
oh conflicts of interest
no cons of interest confirmation of
minutes
i mean uh councillor blacky seconded it
yeah um any matters arising
none of that hot um reputational
presentations um
i'm not into them so right we'll go on
to
reports um so we've got 5.1
joanne welcome
it's page 15.
thank you very much so this report is
seeking approval for
an amendment to the rolling capital
works program
originally in the cuban channel renewal
section of the program
we had a project for otaki street cuban
channel renewal
due to shovel ready projects being
undertaken
on oteki street we're proposing to
push that project out to the following
year
and instead carry out the williams
street urban channel renewal
cass street to seoul street what we
don't want to
have sorry out of breath from running
upstairs
um is for us to do the cuban channel
renewal in otaki street
and then have it damaged during the
stormwater piper construction
we are aware williams street is a very
high priority
for the kaiapoi tuahiri community board
so we're suggesting that comes forward
i'm happy to take the report as read
other than that if there are any
questions
any question
moved by council becky got a seconder
second by the mia ox
sticking by robbie um council blackie
isn't it i mean in other words you're
going to do it twice so well done joanne
yeah any more
speakers no just do it
um the the otaki street
kerbin channel after you've done
immediately after so you
do do it all in one or is that
it is preferable to do at in williams
street rather so we can certainly look
to how the timing can work in with or
follow on with the shovel ready projects
but because this budget has to be spent
this financial year
the timing wouldn't quite work so it
would come out in next financial year
anyway so we'll work with shovel ready
team and see whether we can get that
accommodated
i'll put that in all in favor
against carried
right down now we've got 5.2 led
lighting
colors and we've got joey and again
should we
breath would have caught up with the
cornea yeah hey thank you
um so this report is a bit of a
follow-on
from a briefing that we did with
utilities and roading on street
lighting a wee while back when we were
looking at and considering color
temperature
and having a look at what was being done
nationally there has been i guess
there's two schools of thoughts in terms
of street light color
from an nzta perspective and a road
safety perspective they are
recommending 4000k lighting
that's because you get better definition
and for a driver
better recognition of issues in the
rogue corridor at night time
but from a a community perspective
and certainly an amount of the research
that's been undertaken
would indicate that 4000k lighting is
more stimulating
and it potentially has effects on people
and insects in in birds
so what we're recommending is a um
a approach where we use 4000k
lighting on our arterial strategic
and collector roads and 3000 k
lighting on our local roads
which are more our residential roads
where
road safety is less of a high priority
than our strategic arterial collectors
one thing we have noted in there is
there was a
deputation i understand from the oxford
observatory requesting dark skies status
we haven't at this stage allowed any
budget
for achieving dark sky status in oxford
it would mean a number of leds that were
put up there around about two years ago
would need to be replaced
and the approximate cost of that was
around 70 000
so i'm happy to take any questions
um councillor duty first and then
council stuart
thank you joanne um just we've just been
talking about
previously about the um the dark skies
for oxford
um uh the observatory is really trying
to get their um
money towards having a i mean what size
um observe what size um
telescope and so they're actually going
to end up with three
and they were wanting to really promote
so just like probably it might be
advisable if they if we liaise with them
because they won't if they're going to
be doing that they won't want bright
lighting
and they were hoping to do that next
winter
counselor stewart uh thank you a couple
of questions
so the differentiation between the um
the light intensity does the 4000
follow our um our crime cameras
so that on strategic you'll be able to
to see as good as you need to see to
identify any
miscreants i believe so and that was
part of the reason why
4000k was put into kaiapoi town center
and that was certainly the advice that
we were given around that time
is that to get that definition and the
best out of our cameras we needed the
the whiter light rather than the yellow
which is
harder to differentiate
thank you and the second question
concerns
the oxford situation if if those lights
that are already
there are only two years old why don't
we
when we're due for replacing or
converting
any other area of of the district
take those oxford lights um
of the high intensity and put them where
we need them and use that budget to do
the amber
in oxford so that in fact you could
you could achieve the dark sky
and is that going to be possible
so that a figure estimate of 70
000 had allowed for that so it would be
assuming that we would be
taking those lights and replacing them
with
a compliant light which would also have
to be shielded
just one thing to note is there have
been some complaints
about lighting in oxford and the level
of lighting
since we have replaced with the leds
if we were to go to a shielded yellow
light i suspect those complaints would
increase
because there will be a perception of a
lower level of lighting even still even
though that's not the case
of i mean presumably the community
embraces this dark sky
concept perhaps there needs to be some
communication around exactly
what that means changing the light um
is that a proposal that you should
investigate with the
community board and and others
um i'll perhaps i'll answer that first
the danger with doing that is the
um council has not got budget hasn't
we've not allocated budget
to um change it it's an ex it's a
request that has come through from a
group and that might actually raise the
expectations of the community
before the council has had a chance to
consider whether it wants to
would consider allocating funding to
allow that
transfer from the 400k to the
3 000 sorry in oxford and so
there there would be um that would there
would be a danger in doing that because
it might raise those expectations in the
community
all right councillor edmund
thank you mr chairman we've had a way
better discussion
about lighting today already in terms of
the district plan
and jared and glenn means down there
are both on the town centre lighting and
decorations committee
and we have a consultant kevin
crowley in terms of
town center lighting has there been any
consultation
or are we working in with other groups
so we get
we don't have the right hand not knowing
what the left is doing
they twist number one i've got another
one too okay
um it's a really good question so what
we have said is specifically
um this proposal would exclude the town
centres
because i think what we need to do is to
address
each town centre holistically and that
is going to be a little bit challenging
because there are
differing needs and ideas for town
centres but getting a lighting designer
involved and how
best to achieve that
where i think it becomes a little bit
challenging is things like pedestrian
crossings need to be lit to a certain
level
which then may not fit nicely with
ambient lighting so
there's a little bit of a challenge
there but i think undertaking that
specific design for the town centres
and having it excluded from this general
approach would be the best way forward
thank you my my second question is
are we changing to led lighting and if
we are
will that provide any cost savings in
terms of maintenance
um yes when we're replacing lighting we
are replacing with
led the process will be quite slow it
will be over a number of years
um and so the second part of that is
cost savings so yes cost savings in
terms of longevity of life
but what we're getting as an indication
from power supplies
at the moment is that they are just
re-spreading their costs across the
network
so it's not necessarily giving us the
savings and electricity that we had
hoped for
and councillor duty
sorry joanne it was just another
question about the oxford one well it is
a question because mine was a statement
before
um um
if i can remember rightly is it that
the extra costs up there is because we
need
more polls per
per area or so the cost that's in this
report
70 000 would be which
isn't put forward as a suggested budget
it's just
noting that that would be the estimated
cost there's no allowance for that at
the moment
but that would be just a straight swap
with
a compliant night skies
light with a shield for the lights that
are there currently
um it doesn't address deficiencies and
lighting
poles or spacings of light poles in
oxford that would be over and above that
just it's probably worth adding to that
it is a good it is a good question
one one of the issues with switching
from
um the incandescent bulbs or the high
pressure sodium bulbs over to
leds is you end up with pools of quite
intense light
and then areas of dark light whereas the
older ones are a bit more diffuse
and if you just change the
leds just the light fittings themselves
and that's something other councils have
found where they've done that they do
start to get those complaints that we've
had in oxford so in an ideal world
you put more polls in but then it
becomes a lot more expensive
uh to to do so it is that that is
definitely one of the challenges of
transferring over to leds
and one question for myself um are we
still
getting that government subsidy of 80
percent that's
gone now has it and that's right that's
gone in the indications from nzta as
there will be no enhanced fire in the
next three year funding period so we're
not anticipating
that still to be available okay
okay right have we got a mover
and um that's same as
um her six point of five point two
thank you just very briefly mr chairman
second up i think i'm very briefed i'm
not going to
just go into the three thousand or four
thousand um just
observation when i was reading this
report was surely the observatory would
have done some sort of calculation
uh when deciding whether there
was a viable option to to be here before
going or in the process of going um
but flummoxed me somewhat reading the
report that they hadn't seen to have
done their homework
i support the report through the
recommendation and
information the report we had quite a
good discussion through the district
plan
meeting earlier around dark skies in
particular and
our view was certainly when looking at
that that
there does need to be some further
consultation with the community of
oxford in particular
community board and also the high school
and the users of the observatory so
i think that mata can come back at a
later stage
but i'm i'm not an expert expert in the
um the uh i recommend
the amber led and all those other things
i i take the advice of our staff on that
and and certainly in support of it
thank you you got any other speakers
council dude the observatory was
actually built by the school
for for that and they probably wouldn't
have back then
thought about all that the light
situation i would say because it's been
up for quite a number of years
but they just wanted now they're wanting
to push it forward
and so this is where it's
coming in because in time hopefully in
time it may bring a bit of revenue into
the school
counselor barney
yes i i don't have a vote on this
committee but i think the way you're
going is
the right approach to try it if it
doesn't work you can always go back
which is the the beauty of it um but the
main complaints i've had about lighting
out our way is always that it's too dark
so therefore i think you're going to get
some pushback and it's
people want to feel safe there's been
crime about
and they want to feel that they can see
when they drive and as you get older
your eyesight gets worse
and driving at night gets harder so i
think
it's a very good approach you've taken
in this report
all right well i'll put that all in
favor
against carried
all right now we go to 5.3
and i don't think we've got sophie here
we do
yeah so kirakoto uh i'd like to cast
your minds back to
november last year there was actually a
motion from this committee
to look at the feasibility of automating
the cam river flood gates to be
tide gates and that was from the kaiapoi
river rehabilitation working party
motion to to investigate for this
council to investigate that
but the motion was to seek whether there
was support from gaitura hariri
and ecan as asset owners before
considering whether the feasibility
studies should be
funded so i
approached the naitahiri ruinanga bayer
and received a report which is the
appendix to this report
which does oppose the
automation of the floodgates for reasons
such as fish passage and
effects on illanga spawning so
because of that the staff recommendation
is to
not seek to fund the feasibility study
so happy to take any questions
any questions council redmond
ah thanks sophie what what was he ken's
position
so i actually was waiting for the
runanga report
before so e can have been supportive of
us inves our council investigating this
uh they haven't been opposed but they
also haven't said that they would fund
anything so i haven't actually asked
them explicitly do you support this
feasibility i mean i think that they
would be happy to have a feasibility
study
but whether they actually would go ahead
with with the automation of the
floodgates um and who would fund what i
haven't gone into that detail
yeah any more questions
all right so is any um counselor blackie
move
you've got a second cancer stewart thank
you i'll be very very brief um
i was the one i recall who insisted on
going to the runanga first because i was
sure they wouldn't buy it and it turned
out i was right
before we spent money either internally
or externally
so um my gut feeling said
the whole scheme was never going to work
anyway so i i don't mind that we're
turning it down
cancer stewart thank you and um i
endorsed those comments
um it was an idea that had been around
for a long time
pushed by certain individuals in the
kaiapoi community
and because it never went away it was
it needed to actually be tested further
and it's got to the point
where it has been looked at to a
cursory degree but the the crunch is
uh does runanga support it and the
answer is no
and the other question of course would
be even if we went ahead
who's going to fund it and certainly i
wouldn't be holding my breath about ek
and putting up any money for it
so yes so this decision is is the
correct one i think
thank you
thank you i'll be voting in favor as
well however
we've got tide gates on the taranaki
stream
they're on the sticks and
with uh changing weather patterns
uh this will come back um sea level rise
and you get that sermon water pushing
even further up
uh causing issues um the taranaki string
that was put there because of
flooding issues from the ponds where
they actually flooded
so prevented backwash into the end of
the settlement
so yet there are places for for tide
gates
however i completely agree that spending
15 at this stage
is money wasted
all right well i'll put that all in
favor
against carried
right so now we've got 5.4
trim road improvements um
it must be joanne again then you've got
me rather than don today
[Laughter]
um so i'll take this report largely as
read
um what i would just note is the tram
road
scheme design report pulls together a
large program of works
along the tram road corridor that would
be
rolled out or phased over quite a number
of years
this would have funding that goes well
beyond the ltp
it's been developed in phases so that we
can stage
implementation the scheme report has
been peer reviewed by opus
and what we have done with this is
prioritize intersections
due to high risk and we are looking
wherever possible in the first phase
providing low-cost interventions to get
good safety improvements
with items such as the rios which are
the
rural indicator advanced
sorry active warning signs um
so i'll just as i said take that as read
and happy to answer any questions
looks like we've got no we have
councillor duty
just um with the early's road one since
you've had those
early indicator warnings it's been very
successful has it
the signs that are on early's road and
john's and
skits road are actually um the stop
ahead advanced warning signs they're
part of a trial
so they're different than the real as
well okay set a speed limit
as you approach right okay but they are
very successful
and i think these ones um it's
anticipated they would get a good
safety outcome and they are have been
rolled out
on the road between west melton and
darfield
and yeah i think they've been very
successful there
councillor blackie yeah i'm supportive
of at least phase one anyway
um but can can you tell me apart from
the those signs we've just mentioned
um just then um how does this tie in
with the overall speed
control of the whole of the of the tram
rate is that is that is that integrated
with this or not is it a separate issue
um it's something we're going to be
considering and bringing to council in
the near future
is how we manage speed on tram road i
think there's a section
from where we're currently doing the
speed limit review
through about just east of ireland road
through to mandeville which could would
likely
be relatively easy to bring down to 80.
the section from mandeville to oxford
road
depot road is probably a little bit more
of a challenging conversation with our
community
but development of a regional speed
management plan is something that i'm
anticipating will be required within the
next three years so that will be
something we'll
need to work towards how we stage and
deliver
our speed management improvements
through the district
council barnett joanne the intersections
that you've got there you've got
obviously some land purchase and thing
but
the biggest thing that seems to be the
issue of some of those corners is hedges
do we have any mechanisms now to
actually try and require improved
visibility
at some of those important corners
particularly um it's two chain road
nest one another that one there with the
angle as well
where the hedges are actually
obstructing visibility
so without growing out over the road
reserve we certainly can
and that is something we here need to
look at that the challenges are where we
have those
triangle boundary corners um there other
than
purchasing a corner snipe and then
requiring and
obviously clearing that it's very
challenging we can't really enforce that
within private property
yeah gordon you
it's it's within the context of tram
road but the
we had the meeting with joe and your
call with
mr harland with the local councillors
and some residents
has there been any update from nzta with
the
intersection we were looking at
intersection improvements including
speed reduction potential is there any
update on that and where
where jim got an nzta got to in terms of
seeing what they could do to fund some
of that program
sorry we did actually inquire about that
around about a week ago
but we haven't had a definitive answer
as to where they are with funding
i understand they're still working on
that they are working on the design
was my understanding but that funding is
something that they were still trying to
secure
in terms of speed we can as part of the
consultation we've got out at the moment
for that 80 kilometer an hour over the
overbridge
that includes the on and off ramps from
the motorway we
had nzta agreement to consult on that
whole lot at one time
so we're just working through that now
we'll have a report
to council early december on that speed
limit consultation
and one question for myself the
designation program
um the long term some of this property
we may have to purchase for this will
that be designated at the same time as
what we're looking at now
um if we have to purchase any of that
land later on
well we designate it for roading this
you know um
i understand the designation process
happens through the district plan review
so that would be when we
are so i guess don is working through
that process at the moment
of um visiting the property owners
we are we are proposing designations
um in terms of timing for the actual
purchase i think that depends a little
bit on each property owner and how
quickly they want to settle that yeah
um what i was meaning to do we actually
need to designate that land
now so the owners know even though we
may not
want to purchase for 20 years for
example
so where we've got a specific design the
likes of
fernside flexton fernside and foonside
road onto
say lehman's where we've got a design
for the intersection
we have designated land i'm not aware of
any on tram road that we need to
specifically take
so not at this stage i would have
thought that probably more just
a small corner snipe or a slither rather
than a larger area
all right does anybody want to move
we've got a secondary
second yeah
i'm here just i think it's a very good
report joanne
excuse me and i think that the work
that's been done certainly identifies a
program
with the increased traffic um or
traffic along tram road that is a high
area now given the development that has
occurred along there it's timely that we
are looking at this and prioritizing it
but the question i asked around the core
intersection on the off-bridge um
off-ramp there is was cause for quite a
bit of concern
recently and we followed a meeting with
jim harlan so
i thought that was a very productive
meeting where there was
some some matters considered so
certainly like to just make sure we
continue to keep
an eye on the pressure on that because
there's going to be with the
northern corridor opening there will be
certainly and the improvements that have
been done there would be great
as we talked about to see if they could
be aligned as best as possible the speed
limit
doing the work that you're doing along
there at the moment reviewing that's
important so
no i support the report thanks for the
work that's been done
council blackie
councillor barnett
tram road's really really important to
those of us who live out
oxford way and i'm really really pleased
to see the improvements it's getting a
lot of wear
particularly from mandible on and those
roads are breaking up
an awful lot so really really pleased
that you're looking at the intersections
we've seen some terrible behavior
on some of those crossroads um near
misses
it's quite scary when you're approaching
them at speed
however and this is always my however
once you get past mandeville
it's basically rural it's a rural
connector road it's really really
important arterial road actually
connecting up our townships into
christchurch city where most people a
lot of people work
and being able to travel on that road as
a proper highway is really really
important
so i get really nervous when people
start talking about speed limits
past that urbanized fringe of tram road
and so anything past mandible would
require quite a bit of
consultation with our community and just
to put it in context my husband leaves 8
in the morning he gets home at 6 30 at
night
and that's with it being 100k speed
limit while people may say it's only a
very small difference to take it down to
it does add on to the commuter time and
that
that impacts on the development of our
district it also impacts on
um the ability of people to have lives
out in our district so
while i totally accept and understand
speed restrictions on some of those
the curvy bit um on the on off
off bridge is the mayor said i am
quite opposed on straight rural roads
that you can see for miles
it just doesn't seem to make sense to me
if people are driving
sensibly then there is no danger to
drive at that speed
in fact it's hard to even keep to 100 on
those beautiful straight stretches of
roads
and all you have to look at is for rural
hazards which is normal
all over the country and rural roads so
just wanted to make put that in as a
comment
that we would need to talk seriously
with the community about
speed limits before we made any changes
past mandeville for
certain
i wouldn't like to put a finger finger
on it but i guess i've probably attended
in excess of 10 000 crashes over the
last 39 years
when i was based in christchurch for two
years running i attended more crashes
than any other officer based in
in christchurch the most common theme
that well the honest excuse i got was i
didn't see it
i didn't see her i didn't see him and
the reason why they didn't see them as
they weren't looking properly or they
didn't stop and look properly
while i sympathise i
am personally very much in favor of the
adk going up
to chain because we've got a dirty great
big school
and a duty great big play center we've
put foot paths in there because we're
trying to get kids to walk to school
so whilst i sympathize that somebody
wants to get to work a minute and a half
faster
i'm extending the 80k through to
mandeville
for a minute and a half i i don't have
an issue with that
i'm not trying to reply right so i'll
put that
all in favor against
carried it
right so now we've got um
report referred from the wooden
committee board project update
requesting support
the shared path and joanne
and glenn
should we let glenn start off shall we
he does a good job um so this report
is seeking approval to proceed with the
detailed
uh design for the extension of the um
ringer wooden path
i'll take the report as read we did have
a workshop with the community board in
mid-september
and following that we've done some
extensive consultation which involved a
one-on-one public consultation
with all the affected residents on the
route as well as the school
and the bowling club um
they we received 34 submissions in total
with 26 of them in favor of option two
the only thing we're asking is to allow
the path to be installed we need
to um install 33 meters worth of no
parking
lines opposite the terrafy here road
that's just to allow a lane shift
for a safer crossing point for the
cyclists
i'm happy to take any questions
any questions council barnett
delighted to see this when is the rest
of it going to happen
to link people from the school through
to the ringer
to to the jewel chroma trail on the ncta
part
so we do have the wider path
along main north road on along the state
highway on the
eastern side of the road it's not signed
as a shared path at the moment or marked
as one
but we can have a look at that
yeah that's right it was it was widened
out for that purpose
um the other thing we are looking in
glenn's been doing some fantastic work
at how we can also connect through
to gladstone road pass the shed path
there so
it's part of that bigger picture that
we're looking at how do we
tie up those gaps and make sure we have
a sensible path that people know where
they're going
so it will be quite a once we get bob
robertson drive
finished we're going to have a really
lovely loop that people will be
wanting to get out onto
any more questions and we've got a mover
and we've got a secondary so we've got
dan and robbie
just to say uh well done glenn i popped
out to one of your
sessions on the uh one of the mornings
um
we had a very good turnout that morning
anyway um
but it was i think you've done a very
good job with the consultation with us
um certainly talking to the affected
parties
along there and i think you've achieved
a good outcome with this so i'm in
support of it
particularly like the picture on page
one two six and um i'd suggest
colleagues if you have a moment have a
look see if you recognize anyone there
in the picture
but um and the little man will it but no
well well done glenn
job well done cheers
nothing yeah no more speakers councillor
barnett
i'm trying to think it was 2008 or 2009
that we started the planning for the
what's now the jill kramer trail
and the intention was to try and link so
that we
knew that eventually we would get a a
wooden tarangiro link
but also then to link wood into wooden
beach which is very very important all
the kids from wooden beach go to wooden
school
and all the residents use the beach and
it
was a dangerous road it was a very
twisty turny road so
it took maybe five ten years to get that
actually finished with a lot of help
from the roading
department and special special mention
of ken stevenson who was instrumental in
helping us there
and the um
what's it called pdu as well were very
very helpful
so the community put a lot of time and
work into that and they did a great job
but it was always in the intention that
there would be a link
and that nzta would come to the party
and and allow us
a lot to look after that footpath and
get people across
now with the lights going in hopefully
in january
um across the road that now makes it
very attractive for cyclists to try and
actually
avoid that nasty ring or a wooden road
intersection
to do the little cut through school road
and then to travel on that eastern side
through
to get out to the beach i saw a cyclist
waiting it rang
at um woody beach road the other day it
must have taken him
we were there for 10 minutes and he was
still waiting to try and get across that
highway one
so i think that would be a really well
used route
if we can get that path to link in it
all the way
and i really applaud the work you've
done to bring it up to school road
captain thank you mr chairman
um i'd like to uh congratulate glenn on
his
achievement i'm not always um favorably
disposed towards cycleways
but i thought this was one that was
really going to be successful
and the consultation and listening
i think we've ended up with um a good
outcome
and um i'm not sure if you're getting
royalties for that photo glenn but i'm
happy to talk to you later
thank you
write a reply from here but i'll put
that all in favor
against carried
now we've got can i just give you a
quick update
on the traffic signals actually nzta
have confirmed today they have awarded
the tender
to fulton hogan fulton hogan have
already been in
and visited the school with ken
terry the policeman and they've got a
plan for how they're going to operate
that
during construction so that's all go
cool pretty good all right so now we've
got reports of information we don't have
to vote on that do we
um
just receive the reports um 7.1
and 7.2
so we've got a robbie
the second uh council award hasn't done
any seconding today
see you're second there cool all in
favor
carrie right now we've got um portfolio
updates myself um
i won't talk about roading much because
we've been doing a bit of that
um probably
we had jared and amir and
myself and um some staff talking to
the new contractors saw the existing
contractors got the new um
um roading contract um they've now got a
couple of trucks on there doing our
potholes around the um town and um
areas and um we've sort of um got an
indication that they're looking it up
and upping their game
and um so it's all positive here um
looking good um
the flexton road's all
on the um cards it's out for tender at
the moment
so um hopefully we'll come up with a
satisfactory
deal on that so that's all for me
annette so
um drainage of stock water council
stewart
uh thank you mr chair um
um the nps fresh water
and the impact on drainage works
um natural wetlands and the hundred
meter buffer around that
has come up from time
at most of the rural drainage groups
over the last couple of months
and uh once we get a very
um a clearer idea about how it all
affects
us our drainage unit and um
and our maintenance program
i would suggest that there's a special
meeting
for the rural drainage groups anyone
else who wants to come along
to explain it so that everybody
everybody understands how
our staff adronis staff
are going to operate going forward to
comply with this new mps
the water race advisory group which
met in oxford on october the 27th there
was a question
about the legal opinion that this
council has
has evidently undertaken
to clarify
will's ability to um as a contractor for
this council to maintain the race system
now from what um i understand that
this was already the question was from
margaret
why are we going for a legal opinion
when in fact we've already got one
um so i just wonder what and i
undertook to ask and um
get back to her particularly
so i'm documenting that question
um and uh just on
the water supply
the way the reports are presented
to the group and also it cuts across
with the rural drainage groups
is there's questions about the the type
of information
that is reported which is this is an
example but
um maybe there could be a review about
how this information
is recorded and conveyed
to these groups because they question
about
could it be done in a more user-friendly
way um
why is the appreciation recorded the way
it is
um this sort of thing and and i think it
does need a review
about how we present
the budget and the ongoing
maintenance and cost centres for these
groups
um and i i'll raise it here because it i
don't see that it comes under any any
other
um committee that i report to which is
the
um and it's a um it's a cycleway issue
and there is a level of dissatisfaction
um
that has surfaced that the wooden sefton
community board
about the walking and cycling reference
group that
um undertook the consultation and had a
meeting and used that being the table
um software is a method for consultation
um what was conveyed was um
there's been absolute silence um since
since people completed the consultation
and as a as a communication
mechanism it didn't seem to be fully
embraced
by some of the woody and sifton people
who were representatives on the group
and i would echo
their concerns to a degree i don't know
i couldn't answer what's happened to
that reference group
and um so i just
tabled that certainly it's been
a month six weeks or more
since and that consultation was
completed through
um being the table software and
there's been a silence so an
update on that would be um
much appreciate it thank you
um would you like um joanne to
respond a bit of that now
i think that um it could go out further
to the
reference board
sorry i'm certainly happy to get an
update out to the reference
group i'm sorry probably the delay in
processing all of that information
there's a lot
for mark to work through because he's
been pretty busy with the
piracy street working group and tied up
there so it's been a little bit of
balancing
priorities and trying to keep that
working group going as well
so he has got started working through
all the feedback there is a lot of it
and he's just trying to process that
and look at some of the questions and
options that he needs to work through
i have booked in a briefing with
utilities and roading for december
to have a look at where we've got to
with the
network plan and we'll also be involving
green spaces
in that discussion but happy to put out
an update to the reference group in the
meantime
thank you joanne right
me again um not much in the um
line to report um but the water
um as you probably realised we've had a
wee bit of a hiccup with
cusp with the boil notice water on with
some um
e coli found and i understand the boil
water
notices being rescinded today but
the chlorine will probably end up having
to stay
in the water system for a fair period
until we
know exactly what's what with the system
because this is their second one
but it it probably indicates
the need for the update but we're
actually got progressing at the moment
because
um the indication we're not 100
certain but the bacteria probably or e
coli probably come from the concrete
tanks that we're
need to be replaced with all the um the
cracks in the concrete so um
it's actually good to know that we're on
to it before we realize
um what the biggest problem was
um the water management plan sort of
comes out
enforced in july the first
and um we're colin's looking into a
um predicament we've got the um
if to keep chlorine out of your water
and the main supplies like
copper and mengura we don't know whether
we actually have to
introduce chlorine and then apply to get
it taken out or whether we can
technically apply before the first of
july so
that's up in the air at the moment so
colin's doing a bit of um
homework on finding whether we can apply
earlier but
um i don't know whether juror can give
us any
information apart from that that's look
i'll
very briefly cover it now um
although colin is giving a briefing
following this that'll get into
more detail but um really the dilemma is
um the
regulator doesn't get established until
the 1st of july
and the regulations require that we
chlorinate unless we have been given an
exemption
and the regulator won't be won't exist
until the 1st of july to give an
exemption
so where colin has been trying to get
some clarity
and certainty there and we're
trying to formalize that because it's a
significant issue for our district
we're working with christchurch and so
on because they also
um will face the same uh dilemma
but but um certainly colin's going to
cover that in a bit more detail
in the briefing you did
so probably won't be here for the
briefing so questions i would like
colin to perhaps to consider is around
um possibility of uv
bringing that forward and other options
can you can that please be covered as
part of those
rather than just i certainly understand
the reason for keeping chlorination in
the interim but
um particularly if there's a risk but i
would like to to know
a bit further around um whether those
other options have been explored and can
be considered place
you want to come up to the table colin
the giraffe legislation we've seen
simply says all
water shall have residual disinfection
in it it doesn't say anything about
unless you've got uv
so doing uv quicker wouldn't get around
the dilemma
of the legislation saying that we have
to do it
so it it wouldn't really
by us well i don't think it would change
anything really
it will give us a stronger case to apply
for an exemption but um
and it yeah it wouldn't stop the problem
of potentially having to turn it on and
then apply for an exemption and then
wait
to see what the outcome of that would be
have we a plan when we have sorry when
we've got
further information to certainly have
some
an information evening or some
information for our community on this
because they're
knowing that community and being
involved in their water supply upgrades
over the years they'll
have some fairly strong views on it yeah
definitely that's
going to be the major thing about it is
as
informing the community and i think the
first step has to be
make sure we've got 100 clarity on the
message we give
and then talk to the community about it
um
so we need to get that first
thank you colin
yes you said that something about the
boil water will be lifted today
is that can you just clarify that
because i've got a lot of people asking
about that
so the boil water notice has been lifted
today uh anyone who's on the
uh text message service will have it'll
be on our website colin
yep yes it's been out by the text email
alert and the council website
and i think
okay alistair was
where yeah i thought he had updated all
the different channels but um
we can follow up on the facebook as well
yep thank you
uh colin what what would be the sanction
if we didn't
chlorinate excuse me on the 1st of july
well as an extreme case we could be
prosecuted
that's part of the legislation now so
similar to the health and safety at work
act they have similar
things there about prosecutions if you
don't follow um
you know if you're intentionally either
negligent or not
doing what the legislation and standards
tell you you have to do so
i don't know if they would start with
that route on the first day they come
into power but that
they could do that
thank you so right here we've got
councillor ryan
on uh solid waste uh well not too much
and not because it's not too much
you're all aware of the your audits and
everything but we're all aware of it so
it won't take up your time
right that was good that's quicker than
mine even
transport i just um further to your
um report mr chair uh
that um had a very good meeting with um
saikon i thought and they had the chair
uh of cycon as well as a board member
the ceo and local manager so it was good
to
have that direct contact and they
welcomed
us potentially coming and meeting their
staff at some stage
and yeah i think it's fair to say that
they really want to do this contract
really well this term so
um both joe and joanne were there as
well and i thought that was a really
good meeting so
thank you for that initiative um paul
i've continuing to have engagement with
jim
harland keeping well keeping the
is the wrong word but keeping um
connected with him
uh around the priorities we have in one
end in particular
um the signalized crossing and thank you
joanne for that update
it's just really important that we keep
that project on track and the other
projects that have been
signaled in one end because the
community
certainly expect that i want them to be
delivered but but
more so than particularly the signalized
crossing but
the other projects it's been a long time
and
from when they were first announced to
still not being any further ahead
jim advised me the other day that the
funding model
the funding case for the other safety
improvements has gone to
up the chain so we'll wait with interest
to see where that gets to but i've
um i'm having a monthly meeting with jim
because it's important that for me that
i
keep on top of those issues with respect
to bloody end in particular
jim
our ceo and i popped to christchurch
city council the other day at their
invitation
and undertook a deputation
with regards to the in this road to
buick street
which is to do with the northern
corridor there is
um with the park and ride
it's to connect with the buses to go
along
uh that route there is a view from
some within the community board down
there that
that the in this road the bearer extreme
area
wouldn't be included in that particular
area and if we're to make
um park and ryden express buses work we
do need them to go along that entire
corridor
even if it were in high occupancy um
vehicles as well but
at the very least uh those peak times
that's where we want
uh see if we want to see that occur i
think the city's got themselves into a
bit of a bind with this particular issue
they were going to resolve it on friday
it didn't get resolved on friday
lay on the table their staff haven't had
adequate
consultation with strategic partners
which includes ourselves i
understand from joey and there's
certainly been a meeting
um today was it today or this week
anyway where they are now reaching out
to us but it's
it's it's a bit late in the process and
the recommendation from the council
staff to certainly to the community
board was
was to not include that as part of the
um
consideration of that making that
express bus
work it's fair to say i think from the
elected level in there
they are certainly on board and want to
see that happen we will have to wait and
see where they get to in terms of
resolve i had some members of the
community board come up to me after we
presented
thanking us for our submission they
weren't able and they certainly
appreciated the
fact that maybe just limited to buses
ideally it should be higher occupancy
vehicles as well but
um small small steps towards the bigger
objective so we'll wait to see where
that
gets to but it's um it was appreciative
of um
getting a heads up from their elected
members in town and that we were
provided the opportunity to go in
and make a submission and its
environment canterbury ourselves
nzta and other parties um
made deputations last thursday so
um and they're all fairly strong in
their message that we need to do this
so we will we will see where we get to
the questions council barnett
dan just on the nltp we
we went to a briefing a while back
before the election anyway um
saying that if we wanted to keep
putting the foot on the bypass issue
that we needed to submit to the 2021-24
national land transport program
irrespective of what the direction of it
is
are we submitting as a council or only
as a regional body
and what is the suggested direction
well i'd further probably get joanne to
probably answer this but yes
we are and we have as i understand is
that right julian
and it does well and that was my point
at the time
too because i didn't see it before it
was submitted either and i had asked
to see that and i expressed my
disappointment
that we didn't get to see that before it
went because i did want to make sure
that that was properly resourced and the
right information has gone there i've
since
found since been assured that all our
projects that we want to see and there
in fact more
than well it's a complete exercise
sorry a complete exercise has been
undertaken with respect to that but i
would have
preferred that we have seen it and that
our council had been briefed on that
before it went
is it when it comes out as the next
draft do we still submit on that draft
at all or
i thought we did get another crack at it
next year
um the nltp projects go through
a moderation process so we've
put in our draft projects but that
goes it does go through a whole process
of checking and
moderating against other councils
projects
and to be honest i think what we come
out with is something less than what we
ask for every time
anyway yeah christian council 30.
and just a question dan please when you
uh was speaking with jim harland
did he mention anything about the tram
road lights proposal
no and i have um i had to go
we caught up after a runa meeting the
other day
and i had to go to another meeting so i
just emailed him this afternoon
just while we're here asking him for an
update on that particular project thank
you
all right thank you right um so i've got
no
questions understanding orders no
general business so
we'll call this meeting to a close at
pm thank you and now we've
got a briefing yeah thank you we've got
a um
series of briefings um
i do know that we've got apologies from
two for quarter past so um how are
other councillors placed in terms of
timing just to give us a bit of a gauge
of how we should pace it
well what time is your next one 7 30
okay
do you plan to eat between now and then
six yeah okay i think six would probably
be we'll try and aim for
for six so there's about um five
points so we'll yeah okay that's
that's a good target for us so um joanne
your
first hang on turn this side
[Music]